ich glaube ich habe mich verlaufen
hallo entschuldigung sind sie von hier
hallo
ja klar
hallo ja klar könnten sie mir helfen
könnten sie mir helfen
können sie mir bitte sagen wie ich zum
bahnhof kommen
bahnhof kammer
sicher aber es ist zu fuß
sicher aber es ist so weit zu fuß
sie müssen mit dem bus oder taxi fahren
vielleicht ist ein taxi zu teuer es ist
besser den bus zu nehmen
ich denke ich werde den bus nehmen
sie können den bus nehmen der vor dem
bahnhof hält
können sie mir sagen wie oft dieser bus
fährt
normalerweise gibt es einen alle 20
minuten
und wo ist die bushaltestelle
gehen sie geradeaus und biegen sie an
der kreuzung rechts ab
die bushaltestelle befindet sich direkt
vor ihnen
gehen sie geradeaus und biegen sie an
der kreuzung rechts ab
die bushaltestelle befindet sich direkt
vor ihm
sie sind sehr freundlich
noch eine letzte frage
ich habe noch eine letzte frage
wo kann ich mein ticket kaufen
an der bushaltestelle gibt es einen
automaten
sie können aber auch die app der
öffentlichen verkehrsbetriebe nutzen
danke für die hilfe
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen tag
für ihnen einen schönen tag gern
geschehen
ich wünsche ihnen auch einen schönen tag
gern geschehen ich wünsche ihnen auch
einen schönen tag
[Musik]
entschuldigung wo ist der reitwagen
entschuldigung wo ist da hat absagen
er ist in dieser richtung ist in dieser
richtung entschuldigung wo ist das regal
mit den pflanzen entschuldigung wo ist
das regal mit den pflanzen gehen sie
dort land gehen sie dort lang
biegen sie links ab liegen sie rechts ab
gehen sie gerade aus
biegen sie links ab gehen sie gerade aus
biegen sie rechts ab
entschuldigung wo ist das museum
sie können es in wenigen minuten zu fuß
erreichen
er geht in die falsche richtung er geht
in die falsche richtung gehen sie diesen
weg gehen sie diesen weg biegen sie die
erste straße links abbiegen sie die
erste straße links ab
biegen sie an der kreuzung rechts
abbiegen sie an der kreuzung rechts ab
entschuldigung wo ist der bahnhof
zum bahnhof fährt man zehn minuten von
hier
[Musik]
halo ist dieser platz frei
hallo
ist dieser platz frei
darf ich mich
ja bitte
entschuldigen sie
ich muss zum bahnhof waren
wissen sie wie viele haltestellen es
noch sind
ich muss zum bahnhof waren
wissen sie wie viele haltestellen es
noch sind
nicht viele noch 6
sie können das auf dem bildschirm dort
oben überprüfen
dankeschön
bitteschön
hallo guten morgen
guten morgen
ich brauche ein ticket um mich in der
stadt zu bewegen
wohin müssen sie fahren
ich weiß nicht
weiß nicht
ich bin zum ersten mal hier und würde
gerne die stadt erkunden
zum ersten mal hier und würde gerne die
stadt erkunden
wir haben eine tageskarte gut für einen
tag
tag oder ein mehr tagesticket
oder ein mehr tagesticket
was möchten sie
ich bleibe für ein paar tage in der
stadt vielleicht wäre es sinnvoller
mehrere tickets zu haben
ich bleibe für ein paar tage in der
stadt vielleicht wäre es sinnvoller
mehrere tickets zu haben
wie viel kostet das mehr tagesticket und
wie funktioniert es
das ticket kostet 50 euro und kann
maximal sechs mal abgestempelt werden
jeder stempel ist für 24 stunden gültig
ich verstehe
wie viel kostet die tageskarte
die tat
karte kostet zehn euro
die tageskarte kostet 10 euro
ist 24 stunden gültig
und kann in jedem fahrzeug in unserem
gebiet genutzt werden
mit dem meer tagesticket spare ich etwas
geld
wie erkenne ich die bereiche in denen
ich fahren kann
haben sie einen stadtplan
natürlich hier ist es
danke dann kaufe ich das 50 euro ticket
hier ist es ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen tag
danke gleichfalls
gleichfalls andere wörter die dir auf
reisen helfen können
[Musik]
zu welchem gate soll ich gehen
zu welchem geld soll ich gehen
wo ist die gepäckausgabe
ich kann mein gepäck nicht finden
brauche ich einen reisepass
[Musik]
ist die fahrkarte für eine einfache
fahrt oder für die hin- und rückfahrt
ich möchte gerne eine fahrkarte für hin
und zurück
für wie viele fahrten ist dieses u bahn
ticket gültig
wie viel kostet dieses abonnement
ich möchte eine rückerstattung
bis zu welcher uhrzeit fährt dieser bus
wohin fährt dieser bus
an welcher haltestelle muss sich
umsteigen
wo finde ich ein taxi
finde ich ein taxi hast du das video
nützlich gefunden
möchtest du weitere videos wie dieses
sehen
schreibe es in die kommentare und
hinterlasst uns ein like